patience I'm delighted to be able to
move to the final declaration of this
count a declaration resolve Paul for the
election of a member of parliament for
Coventry Northwest on Thursday the 8th
of June 2017 I
Martin Reeves being the acting returning
officer at the above election do hereby
give notice that the number of votes
recorded for each candidate and the said
election is as follows G Michael Stanley
mark Simon UK Independence Party you Kip
1525 gray Stephen Robert George Green
Party 666 Hilton Andrew John Liberal
Democrat 1286 Kotecha recién the
Conservative Party candidate eighteen
thousand three hundred and fourteen
Norris Kieran Michael Thomas independent
1164 Robinson Geoffrey the Labour Party
candidate 26 thousand ninety
the total number of pilot papers
rejected was 88 and the turnout for this
constituency was 66
0.42% and I do hereby declare that
Jeffrey Robinson is Juli elected
[Applause]
thank you very much very first of all
thank you miss returning officer and
then everybody that's worked so hard in
the official capacity with the usual
dedication and enthusiasm we come to
expect in country throughout the
campaign particularly in the polling
booths and see me here in the hall also
the police and security services has
been of the same high standard as we
have over the years come to expect I'm
very touched and moved by the results as
you can imagine but it's not down three
it's down first of all and as always
sort of my long-serving most loyal and
most brilliant agent market Lancaster
was living tonight Margaret that makes
it ten out of ten and that very very
Sanders isn't bad I think it's a record
of which you in particular can be very
very proud all set up then to the
daughter rachel has been with me
throughout the campaign at my side
giving the same sort of support and she
is ready a chip off the old block now
before I come to mention the generality
all the people to help me throughout the
campaign I'd like to mention bubble ed
ran and can imagine done a fantastic
supportive job an organizing job with
really efficiency and commitment and I'm
very thankful to you I can't see me
while the seeding but you know that I'm
very grateful to it and
very much indeed there thank you very
cogent Alice alright thank you very much
indeed you deserve all the praise has
been heaped on you by myself and others
looking beyond commentary tonight it
some has been result in many respect for
one thing I think is clear and that is
that the Labour Party tonight
emerges United the United in a way that
none of us thought that has possible a
year ago of six months ago we it is
clear that we the Labour Party is the
only political force in the United
Kingdom that can bring together the
whole country this clear it's clear that
the Conservatives have failed and
miserably failed in that respect this
clearly results in Scotland and Wales
show that only the United Kingdom could
be brought together only by the Labour
Party so I say tonight we've held
together we stuck together and we will
always remain a united strong Labour
Party as long as we do that and I can
look back over some period of time now
with a great pleasure pride and
privilege of representing the people of
Coventry this is my last word and thanks
in particular the people of Coventry of
Northwest relate to me over the years
it's like the ups and downs that have
come to any political career to another
fine victory tonight thank you all very
much to all of you in Coventry Northwest
I'll continue to be the same MP as you
always known the last decades now thank
you very much indeed I'm here when you
need me and always and wherever and for
whatever you need for the country the
Labour Party's there we wait the call I
think sooner or later is clear now the
part of return and forcing government
sooner or later bracing now we've
survived the worse we've come through
congratulations
to everybody in my party tonight thank
you very much
[Applause]